okay sexy thoughts wait free waffles did
I just say that out loud what sorry I
forgot at the store I couldn't remove
her all day I'm ready now I don't think
you are
just admit you're not into sex it's kind
of like your porn a phobic try saying
something racy you need to decide it's
me or the porn
[Music]
I want your hot throbbing you write love
just coming to check to make sure
everything's fine what what no no no I'm
just medicating cheating meditating wait
why do you look so good
I met someone so I made a sex to-do list
best breakup ever
Oh God click question for you do you do
Pilates or oh wow do you know what you
really half-ton 2 over a new lease get a
dance
don't you think it's a little bit out of
my league you're just afraid to get back
on the horse it's like riding a bike or
maybe a pogo stick
[Music]
it's like one ghost and you might
Patrick Swayze
okay tell me everything I need to know
about you sure you want to know yeah
you're right could be the end of
something good before it even starts no
it could be inside of something good
that doesn't have it that is corny
I just want to find out if this works
actually sir I've got it on right now
you mean you're wearing it now Louis I
don't think you put a ration cream on
your lips
[Music]
you